you
all right let's do this three Oh time
control queen master who is the third
seed we are paired up again
let's try caro-kann land
range caro-kann all right my nights are
happy
are all happy so far no issues let's
point it there King if the bishop played
the g5 I would break the pin
let's go with this White has wasted some
time I don't want that exchange even
this is my good even ounce of a good
Bishop let's just get on with this break
I don't need any more support for it
double-g ponds and now that this is a
whole I want to hop to it
clean
t7 is good pressure on the night
and now this is a whole let's get there
so g3 and c4 or both either occupied or
IED up by my Knights think I want to
just go here straight away a knight on
f5 could be pretty good as well he's not
playing
um let's actually return I wouldn't mind
giving this knight up for the bishop I
think I want some pieces to be exchanged
the minor pieces because
if it's a major piece specific position
I'm definitely the preferred side
because there are some weak points here
I could take that bishop right now I
feel like there's some fancy tactic
right around this point could just throw
rook in the seventh
just trade a bunch actually like how
about this and then take the night out
if he goes there no I was thinking about
this but let's move forward
and how about we sneak this rook in
just write a little bit of a some trades
now we're going to in the end pick up
upon
all right how do we how do we win this
from here clean to be seven or
queen-to-be to tacking a to preparing to
double I just want to stop the Queen
from moving and the Bishop from moving
because I crashed through a G to kind of
all bottled up now their queen is trying
to get active over here I don't even
want to allow that this night can't go
here to maybe interfere with my okay I
got to a faster a little bit faster yeah
there's that move
this which is netting the night that was
the minority attack that I put into
action there none of this exchange Carol
and in the end it saddled white with a
weak pawn
let's take with the night because it
throws a punch at the Queen and I will
return it also kicks the Queen off of
this and next up we could
I guess we're just going to go here
um
and f7 I got to go a little bit faster
night here and then we get some material
not converting this very well at all at
all yeah there was a much better way to
do this
clean exchange I am definitely happy
with
a lot faster and let's just convert this
okay they're giving me stuff now and
just push this pawn not too fast
got that promotion square covered now
stalemates i'll stalemates no stalemates
no stalemate
that's not stalemate I have one square
okay back to tournament land Carol Kahn
exchange and kind of shuffled a bit with
the pieces Bishop d3 Bishop e2 9 2 h2
and meanwhile I was making progress on
the Queen side and created to target
that target fell and then it kind of
felt like dominoes but the conversion
was not was not the greatest thing
around yeah okay
we got two points in the tournament so
far
hmm let's just support d4
okay so I may end up saddled with an
isolated pond that is exactly what we
have but in a position where it is uh
they took on sea for a bit early
belongs here bishop probably on g5
though right now they're throwing a
punch at my bishop so let's go which
target I'll do I want to stay on
actually don't even have to move my
bishop I could consider this
to go here
I uh page seven-night b5 is now a threat
a six stopping that in preparing for b5
is probably a good idea
so I'm going after the dark square
bishop
we nice typical
those three
as well when I have this x-factor bishop
I'm going to try to make sure his
presence is felt
so a great way to do that would be to
put pressure on this night
poor his post and if he ever moves
well he's the most important kingside
defender so that's what I'm looking to
do there's a bit backward the
LightSquared bishop will not be a
contributor in defending the black king
so I'm looking at these ideas if he goes
elsewhere
like cannot afford a double deaf pawn
structure bishop in Queen a rook lift
okay so they're stopping the structural
damage but they're working
they're now in a pin this brings to mind
ah this brings to mind
a night to be four is a bit annoying
when it's now let's jump in here
actually here I'm trying to take
advantage of the pin in multiple ways in
this case or in this case this I don't
know if I'm so afraid of because I could
take on h7 and then take here restore
the material and the attack continues
night Bishop and Queen is playing and
the rook is now long off from helping
these two are not yet playing clean side
is not in the ball game yet
they're under a minute
you
okay so I could ignore the threat
against my bishop and just proceed with
this plan of inflicting a structural
defect on their Kings side
I would have liked to kept my to keep my
LightSquared bishop around and I could
have probably backed him up but I'm
looking for something much more direct
now and this is going to lose flat-out
a common uh air that's made
and Alaska would be proud when you see a
good move you look for a better one this
is definitely a better one because it's
leading to mate on g7 they resigned
all right six points is in first 48
players are now in there
6 5 5 4 4 4 I'm one of the fours with
fire
okay mark is up let's try an e for a
game
why not
a French no thanks
listen to a king's indian attack
that's where we're headed so g3 Knight
f3 Bishop g2 you'll see these standard
moves
soon enough
I could play e5 but not just yet
when is the right moment well when I
could be certain that it can be
maintained
and right around now is the point I
believe it can be maintained night here
rook here Queen here Queen here
with the rook multi-purpose defend and
also vacate f1 this is the journey the
knight would like to take actually I am
NOT certain of that's a very committal
move that might be
there's some serious issue with that
normally you want to keep these guys
staying so this he's kind of sticking
his head out and he might get
you might just get captured in some
lines so are they preparing g5 and in
reply to Bishop f4
maybe that would be pretty crazy to do
or pee sack but we're just going to play
it safe not even give them that
opportunity
I quickly touched on this idea of Knight
f1 H - but Knight f1 to e3 is also an
idea
especially when the queen is on c7
because Bishop f4 Knight e3 is all of a
sudden threatening Knight takes d5 we
may see this take shape soon let's start
with Bishop f4 this I don't have to
necessarily capture on g5 so now we're
going to play here and if ever is a
piece arrives on this square alright I
missed that move
I totally missed that there's that night
move
oops
okay taking a
backwards here I did not for some reason
I didn't see Knight to g6 but what I was
going to point out is that there's some
sacrifice and then a push with the
double attack against the Queen and some
piece that maybe on d7
I have fallen for that many times I
don't want this e-file to open up I'm
willing to just go back home
I guess I'll be making use of g3 with my
night
I think I just want to give him a shove
really soon
see three okay right around this point I
don't feel like I have any attack
let's take and I'm going to try to close
things up some I want to fix some of
their ponds on light squares so he's not
going to hurt me anytime soon maybe
maybe I could still attack throat rook
on g1 g3 double up so he's not bothering
me I don't I don't foresee this pond
moving
where does my night wanna go he's kind
of awkward I prefer to have him here
I think I could afford a
maneuver
if I did this there's this move and
they're breaking things open pretty fast
that's what they're going for
for that is a good idea so right around
this point they're realizing that the
RIP move probably wasn't best
not sure what that's doing that's going
to be annoying to me
let's start with this controlling here
that's something that might be struck
out one day
and defending here
so he's actually a really strong knight
combined well with the bishop and
putting pressure on these two
here I might be able to get away with
some captures and now I'm taking I'm
able to take here and I'm going to do so
with the night not the bishop if I took
with the bishop they might have a piece
sack and then a pin he's really
important really really important to now
they're running into a fork
thirty seconds left
Oh
material let's get my bishop out of the
way
I'm not thinking so much about these
guys moving I'm just trying to double on
the G file now continuing and I feel
like there could be some sacrifice very
soon or some undermining of this
structure if the bishop isn't here
anymore like this so here and then I get
to do this next and this is getting
broken down really fast with cheque
and
five
I'll get the Queen
these two if the king is on this rank
I'm able to askew
I could take here
move with discovered check and I'm just
getting the clean now and where's the
May
the rook let's check and we got me in a
couple they're down on time back to
tournament land
okay we
dates there are 54 players in here now
I see Jeff 2.0 is in there Shawnee Sean
chest lion Ferrari ten
not before already most of you are
probably familiar with to Moo
[Music]
don't even know how to
announced that one
I
walker
a Sicilian at Skywalker I guess II six
um okay let's go with this
I want to point out a weakness in whites
position d4 d6 or weaknesses this is one
of the the more accessible of the two
and let's defend the bishop if I develop
my knight there's some Knight takes pawn
when we're going to go with this night
um yeah there's no reason not to go to
f6
and what more I think I want to just
give the
tonight a shove right now
let's do it now
okay and we're going to watch over the
weaknesses in my camp as well d5 is very
weak
these two are weak for why these two are
weak for me
now things are different I no longer
have a backward pond and I have the
better of the two bishops this will
factor in my nights now sit on good
squares they are focused on this square
and I'm focused on this one and he
should probably dive right in do I do
this only after rook trade click
exchange probably not no reason to give
up control of the file and only then go
here I'm hitting the bishop this is a
serious blunder he's the only defender
of the bishop
actually I'm threatening maybe to take
and then take here so they duck that
and how about we play here preparing to
expand what am i gaining from doing this
well I at least
the stability of the knight on c3
structure is changing some
could take now this is a newly open
square for a night you would love to be
there
there as soon as possible I may just
have to work around a night here
and I think I could
let's see any issues with
around a night here
a little bit annoying is
what was I going to say oh wait night
right here that bother me
no I don't think so what was bothering
me a little bit as if I jumped right in
here straightaway night to be six stops
this b5 expansion night here forced the
Bishop and pawn but I have this move and
that's what I was calculating I don't
think I gained anything from taking here
let's just keep the tension no reason to
really so maybe I take maybe a push at
one point
works
Oh actually here here oops here here I
could take the bishop then take the
knight with the fork
to go somewhere else back home or a for
defending c5 would be annoying so let's
not do that
so they have a strong
but I have two very good nights on dark
squares okay
step up here
I'm fine if they take my bishop
recapturing with the piece I'm taking
with the pond because this was their
only good square for the night
so I've eliminated that I split up my
structure but he plays a very important
role
night is uncertain and now this is a
blunder because I get to take here
removing the defender v2 and I'm on the
rook
this would generally be a very poor
decision to take out a bad bishop like
that so now the house is just following
and resigned
15:14 I'm in the 12 area
two minutes left these tournaments fly
by
let's see what we get
you
- moo-hoo is currently the tournament
leader with 19
okay to move oh maybe we could turn it
into a Benoni
let's see maybe after see for ya and
we're going to try to snake Benoni
couple games already played during the
stream castle rook to e8 okay that move
bothers me Bishop to g5 what are you
going to do with the e pawn they're just
going to move on forward here
I play h6 first wait a second if I ask a
question of this Bishop doesn't it have
to take my knight as otherwise I take
here so now I can break the pin and then
Knight takes e4 I might even have Knight
takes e4 after Knight takes g5 they try
a piece sac so I could do this and ready
to move the knight with the discovery so
like that or actually Bishop takes
Bishop I take the knight discover
checking around the Queen so we're
taking here I don't like that my Kings
side has been compromised but I have at
least one upon I take here there's this
to have to worry about I think I just
want to keep my dark square Bishop
around for defense of my king my
weakened King side or do I insert a
check I'm not sure queen a5 I'm not sure
what that really accomplishes maybe yeah
maybe I should have done that let's get
in d6 before maybe they clamp down on my
entire Queen side I might have to just
run in Reverse with many moves yeah this
is one of them
if they try this kind of stuff Bishop to
g7 my king could hide on f8 I'm not
going for that but they're going to
target d6 I think or maybe clearing the
way for that Queen move but isn't that
short-lived Knight to f6 the Queen has
to find a new home I might be able to
develop further with tempo Queen f3 she
gets trapped
she has officially trapped no good
squares the bishop g5 is one align is
one that I've struggled with before I'm
not quite sure how to deal with that
because they had an opportunity for d6 I
think maybe instead of playing e4 so
they're just giving me a oh they're only
giving up the Queen
they're only getting a bishop for the
Queen they could have gone to the e-file
enforced a rook takes Queen let's watch
some light squares this is where I'm
sensitive f5 and I just want to trade I
could take this pawn to a lot of
different things
nine h5 and f4
let's do that just block the bishops
pressure against d6 even if it costs
costumey structure-wise on the Kings
side I'll take this pawn and then here
next
and this move if they go here I'll take
the rook even though it allows a fork
and let's just get rid of the tricky
mate the tricky guy one minute warning
where's the mate should be very close by
there it is the bishop takes away that
flight square back to tournament land
I'm at the 16 mark 27 minutes left
okay
that one was a bit of a No
disaster Knight takes e4 and this
aggressive-looking queen h5 move it'd be
a different story if she could at least
resign on h5 for one move but I was able
to basically develop even though it
wasn't a knight going from the initial
rank to you know f6 it was still
basically me moving forward and forcing
my opponent backwards okay so what do we
do from here we have the bishop pair I
don't feel the need to do anything fast
let's just take with the Queen so you
may want to swing over here once this
point is challenged okay a queen
exchange I'll just take here let's see
how they recapture I should be fine no
matter how they recapture
castle and put a ruck on the C file soon
I prefer to go with the F rook maybe
this is an idea let's get here first I'm
going also with the F rook because my
King given some moves he would like to
sneak over and I think that's already
the time to do that
King here this is creating some
weaknesses here this is a point I'm
eyeing up Knight to g4 at some stage I
don't know if I want to go over any
further one step is good enough for me
let's let's factor in this a pawn let's
take into account the rip okay playing
very fast let's let's play this move not
quite sure what I'm doing that I
continue to pull off these moves let's
give my opponent worth a little bit week
he's the only defender of this square
this Bishop has him under control and
now I think they're going to find it
extremely difficult to defend here now
that my bishop controls this square it
may just be winning a pawn now
surprising enough okay the knight could
go and reverse to defends now but then I
pick up this pawn
mmm on takes I have this maybe they go
into pac-man mode so they threw up these
pawns pretty fast this f4 move is really
the crew
that is definitely off
pointing upon and the exchange now and
it's just going to crumble from here
because we're getting any for soon as
well so simplify simplify simplify up
material 134 left even on the clock
let's just drop him all the way back I
want to kick him without allowing night
here I can't do that just yet though
let's push him he's passed if I do this
I drop e6 okay I'll just come all the
way back stay off of this open file
he'll probably just get struck out if I
went here and now we shoo him away the
piece that's in my territory and soon
we're going to continue to advance in
fact we can win this pawn next the lone
defender of c4 yeah they're missing
stuff
King g2 knight they're back to
tournament land 22 2016 is where we're
at 64 players in this one okay let's see
we get next
somebody anybody
you
f-for in that game they could have done
without f4 didn't really accomplish too
much ok let's try another D for moral
chess on board let's try the Trump off
scheme
ok
and let's
this night straightaway
they react
I'd be more than happy
just recapture and develop a little bit
so that's what we have and we're going
to get in a quick III and c4 right now
let's do C for right now let's
immediately put pressure on their Center
okay so this pawn the C pawn decided to
take on a conservative role and um I
don't think I gained anything by doing
this move before this one so let's just
get on with castles this pawn is pinned
so that's how their unpinning got it we
trip to c1 probably this one
% why this one but I don't see any other
file being relevant yeah this is really
just one file that's probably going to
open up I have this move and reply so
what's the plan from here baby moose a
ch3 a 3 B 4 B 5 could be a Queen side
expansion this feels a bit uncomfortable
could I shake and after this we take
twice on C 8 and then I Winnie 7
let's keep the tension I don't need to
prep be far with a three I don't have
any fear now of the C file opening up
that move I didn't consider
okay I'm going to take and hmm
this night may end up trying to get into
this square which concerns me
I think I'm just gonna have to deal with
him
yeah he's going to return if I'm given a
moment I'm going to shoot for this or
maybe even this move why not this move
right now
let's do this move right now break in
the center
that was something that was definitely
interesting because this was as soon as
I played b4 c4 becomes a whole
and let's get here
miles can open up on my terms let's go
with this guy I'm still just keeping the
tension
Kings Hut let's go here opposite the
rook and king or excuse me off of the
same file as the rook and the king
one I may try to double like this or
this I haven't decided
Oh
[Music]
let's go here actually
sneak in like this
taketake and then here I could look for
that kind of stuff many different ways
the structure can change here they could
take okay and now my roots look silly
actually yeah their capture made my
rooks look kind of silly I can still try
to pry things open over here but yeah
they probably need to relocate
and let's do that straight away taking
here fixes upon on a dark square so he's
not the happiest piece around now my
rook is supported so we start with this
one first and we're going to look to
form a battery here soon enough
we got that
I'd like to triple up if they if I could
they have to stop rook to d7 so one of
these two and actually I could end up
winning upon so that's why there's some
hesitation here but it could exchange
both trips and then Queen takes c6
they come down and give a check but I
could go here and then I'm threatening
to get to their back rank and deliver
mate soon
combined with the night soon the night
and queen is are basically attacking the
queen and the bishop is really I don't
see it as a defender so I think that
this one's already busted
rook to d7
they're offering a queen exchange this
is sensible
good move I think I could still just go
in for this and enter a rook should be
dangerous enough I think she's going to
push here
I overlooked this idea
okay King I needed to help stop this
passer he's not even going to be in time
um I should have done things a little
bit different there
when that pond
this guy no okay so I guess in the end I
was still going to be able to win that
pond but definitely got a little bit
scary
gotta go faster
can mine I do that's good
I take my night gotta go fast
drop that
pressure
I'm burners in there
that's what this is
down two
time burners
you
holy cow that guy had some wheels my
good
never ended like that got him on the
clock aroni
oh wow that guy flew
expecting that
holy cow okay how to adjust going from
like ultra bullet speed to we have three
minutes now
my god
who
okay
take
they're taking with the night
okay
take care
that game should have never
it should've never went down like that
let's go here
King upon
I thought that that guy's time was never
going to go and I can run out
okay winning the phone and then I could
take here how to do it
I almost feel like I don't want to take
their because they get some pressure
against my queen side and I struggled to
develop
yeah I just don't even want to take
I don't want to take that night
I'll take the night but
Who am I kidding I've taken upon this
isn't it any pressure I just played b3
I'm up to clear pawns will pull him back
that wasn't a difficult to defend they
have to block with the bishop otherwise
they're not a pickle
yeah they just resign they're going to
end up in a pen I wasn't going to take
it I was going to look to get to the
second of the seventh
man I'm still thinking back to that last
game
what did I do wrong
exchange Queens and I should have then
played maybe Knight to g5 instead of
entering on the second
you
this guy going to move doesn't
to be here he left the game huh what's
the story with that white didn't move
black is a winner okay ticker of time
let's try an e for a game only 13
minutes left so two more games for sure
let's try a standard French now so No
93 no King Kings Kings Indian attack
with d3 alright so this is a French win
water
not c5 in this
you know
let's just ask him a question straight
away I think clean ji4 is a move but not
very familiar with that that is a bit
early now we're going to go with h4 h5
clampdown and
let's follow through here I like these
two ponds combating a court grip
difficult to move either of these two
ponds so play is going to come about
probably another they're going on the
queenside so
how do we treat this
to give up this strong point so I'm
thinking about f4
or I could just reinforce it good enough
with the night that's what the computer
would do computer win playoff for
this is best it's developing I don't
need a pond to support this night here
if they put more pressure on it I'm
there to defend it they can only they
could only defend 'if I've with one
minor piece and I can always have two on
it and I'm also prepared to meet this
with Bishop Texas otherwise takes Knight
takes I dropped the bishop so that's I
was there voicing it for that moment
there before making the Knight f3
decision but this was a variation that I
saw and I was prepared to give up my
dark square bishop
if that happens keep in mind when this
exchange came about that was blacks good
bishop that they gave up so right now
I'm giving up my bad bishop they gave up
their good bishop for one of my Knights
and right now if this exchange comes
about they are giving up one of their
knights for my bad bishop in the end
what results is a good Bishop for me in
a bad bishop for them
so let's put my good Bishop to work
there's probably not a better diagonal
than d3 to h7 for him he ties in well
with this guy on g6
how to move forward I could try to scare
him away but I don't like that that's a
pretty weakening move I can also look to
just pull my Bishop back and preserve
him maybe I should have considered that
one move earlier now I'll just develop
here clean here is not bad this move
with 95 is also an idea I'm not thinking
about castling in either direction I
don't want to pull my rook off of this
file there may be a rook up and over
idea especially if the knight leaves
they're lining up c5 maybe we could just
go with g4 g5
you
um let's go here
I'm doing this so that I could step here
and then drop my knight in
for some reason I mean I didn't want to
go here because the night I didn't want
to go here because I'm blocking the rook
I just want to go here and be stable is
the thing so there we go he's defended
against any night move and my bishop
being under fire let's jump in here I'm
prepared to give up my bishop for that I
even though it's a good bishop for
Knight
both end up with kind of bad Bishop's if
this happens but I have a bad bishop
that is much more active so this is what
you're seeing right now my bishop is
outside of the pawn chain theirs is
inside
let's go here it's a hole it opens up
the square for my bishop
and I think right around now maybe
preparing to play g4 g5 next especially
if the hrickos here and there's no fear
of my bishop being in trouble they're
not doing that though let's step forward
they're giving up the exchange
and are trying to hunt down my pond that
next
give this night a boot
move the queen is the only defender
let's go here
tricky Knight is around very careful I
think their Knight is struggling he is
struggling he is gone the Queen needed
to stay on this diagonal
I know here with my king
and let's not go too slow
The Rock roof
what is that
and went into time burning mode too fast
maybe
back to tournament we got that one 36 22
27 and change looking like only one more
game will count for the tournament
razor sharp only okay
- try the benoni again
the snake baloney
let's see what we get a slippery snake
okay let's see how White's going to
treat this okay I'm going to go here
straightaway okay d6 was a move instead
of castles and it's just
entirely different ballgame
be challenging this bishop next acquire
the bishop pair yes or no
find out I didn't do anything to stop
this advance so now my majority is in
motion they did without a form this trip
belongs here and that move I could play
Bishop to b6 now without dropping b5 not
like in the that one game now long ago
or just play c4 straight away I like
this first keeping the tension just for
one more move because if I push straight
away the knight is happy to move and the
bishop is also happy as well
so next I could push
you
maybe I deployed
first let's develop my bishop I don't
think this is there's anything happening
on this on these diagonal actually now
he wants to be here to watch out for
this so here's the thing I'm going to go
here first I guess I'm just going to
work around the night this move I could
play night here first or this move this
would be the fancier the two
I'm doing this now because I want to be
able to move forward and reply to f4 so
this is a nice jumping point and he's
coordinated well keying in on f2 they're
ignoring that
and they're giving the apon this this
night really kills the Queen she's not
seeing the world so well let's just
break up this and we're going to win
this pawn how I want to move forward I
don't want to budget this night I want
to keep him eyeing up that f2 Square at
any point I feel like I could win the
exchange now they're just cashing out
but they're giving up the rook for
Knight but they're not getting enough in
return I don't have to damage my
structure and now in that move I could
probably just go here and
uhh
you
mmm let's not think too much
you
let's not think too much okay that move
going to take my night out okay now
they're really asking for trouble I'm
going to give the exchange back I think
yeah oh god these bishops are killers
take let's say
yes
the night as to block here going to g2 I
take and win the Queen he has not had to
go to f3 so the Queen could recapture
back to tournament I guess we're going
to get one more in
yeah they did without a for is this the
guy where there was that crazy race at
the end now not this player okay d4 c4
we're taking here and not following up a
d4 straight away so they're gamba ting
upon I guess we're going to take
not familiar with this game but I've
seen it before I'm not sure what its
name is it even has a name I don't think
that there could ever be enough
compensation I take is Knight to e4
going to be an issue I'll just I'll just
take and get on with some more
development I probably could have backed
up but I felt that after Knight to e4 I
didn't have a good way to defend the
knight I could have played rook to c1
okay
how to continue
castle
I guess eight three or this move this
gives me the I got the dark square
bishop back
let's take here there pausing a moment
for this Bishop h3 move
I have ways to defend 91 is more secure
capturing they're considering that movie
but I do have this move yeah so let's do
a little calculation here Queen here to
maintain the pin
and they have f4
now excuse me here Queen g5 then I run
away at the night if Queen takes Knight
pawn takes Bishop some maneuver of a
rook over here to here is not working my
Knights they're controlling I think this
is best defend a mate throw a punch at
the Queen and I get to safely move my
knight not here because after this
there's that so I probably just go here
or actually what's wrong with Knight
takes b7
nothing really but I don't know if I
want to allow this kind of counterplay
erect even step foot on my second rank
it's not spend too much time here
let's just go here
some of a piece
I'll have a damage king-sized structure
okay let's go here
they're trying to get this stuff in but
it's not in time I'm two moves away from
contesting a rooks presence on the G
file and that's enough and it takes two
moves for their Brooke to get on the G
file so I'm there in time
the Queen will not be enough so I see
that as you know the rook is here my
rook is here and it's they offset and so
what remains is just a black queen
this diagonal will be
secured if there's ever some check at
the moment there isn't
I could drop f2
that's not even though
three
guys let's go here this one was more
important
about now I'm looking to attack
I'm the one who's opposite there King
route to g3 comes to mind
check doubling and then I'm the one
who's throwing punches this Queen is
close to being trapped in fact if I take
here now let's start with this and then
I could take here next and this is just
a gonner
g5 the queen is hit and I'm turning a
night move with discovered check
here's an instructive moment right there
when they tried to get away with the
in-between move it just was not working
is there a mate
win the rook something better
think so it's just going for it
material
key in on this square right here we're
soon going to have all major pieces
pointing at g8 Queen could knife in on
these squares
just trying to get out of my Rex way
here we are
sneak in
let's just take
and give a check
you
another check and this is
gunner
you soon
okay that's going to do it eleven
registered there for the tournament that
twelfth one did not count for the
tournament
81 players in all forty twenty four
twenty two close one there for second
and third let's see all the pages real
quick
two three four five
almost there I forgot to go to the pages
in that bullet game
or that bullet tournament that we did
earlier
okay to the 80 of you that took part in
this one good games all alright